winter is coming and the landscape
continues to change the lion and the
rose you may remember the last time I
had said that there were a number of
things that I really wanted to see start
getting shaken up because I either felt
they've been stagnant for a little while
or I wasn't loving with the direction
they were going well you know what
pretty big shake-up by the end of this
episode
unfortunately this being Spore the free
I can't talk too much about this which
actually makes this a little bit of a
difficult one to do a review on but I'll
do the best I can we can start with
what's going on north of the wall I'm
getting really interested with where
they're going with bran and how his
abilities as a war again whatever else
is going on with him is really starting
to eat away at him and really given this
drive in this determination that we
haven't really seen what the character
before he's just sort of been there he
always felt like there got to do
something with him eventually well
they're really starting to do it now we
touch base once again with Theon Greyjoy
who thankfully is no longer being
tortured but we are seeing the really
serious damage that has resulted for
what he's been through and it's clearly
not just about the physical mutilation
that he endured last season this guy is
beyond damaged at this point but you can
still see just underneath all the beaten
down and just ready to give up there's
still this this little spark of
something that is you just get the
feeling it's waiting for the right
moment to lash out again and I like
seeing that I'm not making the call that
that's actually what will happen cuz
trying to predict where this show's
going is a fool's errand but it's just
the vibe I get off the character and I
like it we finally get a little bit of
time with Ramsay snow doing something
aside from torturing Theon and we get a
little bit of his dynamic with Lord
Bolton now it's interesting watching
because before our main point of
reference for a father and a bastard son
was Eddard Stark and Jon Snow and what
Lord Bolton and Ramsay have going on
definitely very different Lord Bolton
sees this guy as a wild dog that he's
kind of stuck with Stannis Baratheon may
be headed in an interesting place I'm
getting in the feel of him that he's
starting to question his faith a little
bit and question his goals and whether
or not he's actually being supported by
the
of light there's nothing blatant about
it it's just a feeling I'm getting and
it's a feeling that intrigues me we
spend a little more time with his wife
who actually may be more fanatical than
he ever was which is a bit of an odd
dynamic but an interesting one but of
course the majority of this episode is
spent at King's Landing as we get ready
for the Royal Wedding Joffrey and
Margaery and the wedding takes up the
vast majority of the run time and you
know in terms of the scope and scale of
this show it's a fairly low-key event
all things considered but it's very
telling and it's nice that the show
slows now for this more sort of subdued
main set piece but it's still telling
you so much about the characters and
about the tension that's building and
already been built between so many of
them I'm feeling increased sympathy
towards Jaime Lannister and it's
building off sort of the insight we got
into him at the end of last season
because part of that you just gotten
used to him sort of owning the
Kingslayer label but then you realise he
doesn't really want that but he's stuck
with it so he made the option I'm gonna
own this but now with his fighting hand
gone you can't help but feel bad for the
guy like the the role that he had chosen
to embrace coz what else could he do has
kind of been taken from him and you feel
a bit bad for him and it's giving him
extra depth and extra layers Joffrey the
reigning douche of all time in this
episode particularly when it comes to
Tyrion and remember I said I wanted to
see a bit of a shake-up with Tyrion well
by the end it looks like he's gonna be
in a new situation starting next episode
and that should be interesting I really
feel like there isn't all that much more
I can safely talk about it was a good
episode just moving everything in a
really interesting direction and giving
you better insight into areas where that
insight feels useful really the only
thing I complain about is that romantic
angle with bran and ptarth and Jamie is
resurfacing again so I didn't imagine it
is there and it has been confirmed
rather solidly again maybe never gets
consummated I kind of hope I just wish
it wasn't there at all but that's the
only thing in this episode I could
possibly complain about it's just it's a
good episode and for longtime viewers
longtime fans what happens at the end of
this episode is gonna be cathartic and
just that alone is gonna make this a fan
favorite episode so I'm gonna ask this
question for those of you who have seen
the episode who do you think is
responsible for the
events that happen at the end of this
episode because these are the more
possibilities for who's behind that who
do you think drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it I only want
to deal in theory though if you've read
the books and you know for certain what
the deal is please don't tell me but
until next time this council is
adjourned